anytime that I want something that's
trendy you know I talked about my
problem with jackets recently I went
home and counted them after I think I
only own seven not the nine that I
reported and I'm donating 1 this week
that I haven't worn in the last 90 days
so I'm just I'm constantly being
conscious of that right I was looking at
another jacket recently and it was like
they didn't have the one I wanted the
black version of like this button-up
jacket that I wanted and they had like
the cool camouflage color one that was
like gray and black and I'm like that's
totally and that's it that's what people
were wearing now but for me as soon as I
see something that is trendy yeah that
is a warning sign yeah don't do the
thing that's trendy yeah because your
future self won't be happy about it yeah
we're gonna tweet that Jess when I
purchase anything like that it's a
jacket specifically I mean it's always
something I'm like is this gonna look
good ten years from now hmm oh my god I
don't want to yeah I don't want to buy
something that's cool now I guess if I
did that and then held on to my clothes
I'd have a bunch of like pastel bright
colors and from the 90s and stuff you
know what I'm saying I think it's a
really good way to positive let's be
well this look good good ten years ten
years from now because often we think
like is this timeless no there's no such
thing as timeless good wear what you're
wearing right now back in the 60s and
you'd be totally fine yeah you were we
were in right now in the 14 60s they
would look at you like you were an
insane person yeah and so there's no
such thing as timeless it's it's maybe a
time period in our life life timeless is
is perhaps a way to look at it
you